President Joe Biden was confronted
Yesterday by Fox news reporter Peter
Ducey about the growing headache that
these classified documents are becoming
for the Biden Administration oh but
David you'll never talk about this say
so many of you that email me I've talked
about it all along oh but David you'll
say that it shouldn't even be
investigated no as I've said all along
investigate everything investigate
everything and come to whatever
conclusions the facts point to the
latest news from the Associated Press
Biden team finds more documents with
classified markings President Joe
Biden's legal team has discovered
additional documents containing
classification markings in a second
location this comes a day a days after
an attorney for Biden's for president
said Biden's lawyers had discovered a
small number of documents
um the person who spoke to the AP
Wednesday said the president's legal
team found additional material
classified material at a second location
they are talking about a garage Peter
Ducey confronts Joe Biden yesterday
about this and here is how that
conversation went
material
let me uh look I'm going to get a chance
to speak on all this God willing soon
but as I said earlier this week
people and by the way my Corvettes in
the lock garage okay so it's not like
you're sitting out in the street but
anyway
yes as well as my Corvette
um but as I said earlier this week
people know I take classified documents
and classified materials seriously
I also said we're cooperating fully and
completely the Justice Department's
review
as part of that process my lawyers
reviewed other places where documents in
my uh of from my time as vice president
were stored and they finished the review
last night
they discovered a small number of
documents of classified markings and
storage areas and file cabinets in my
home and my in my my my personal Library
this was done in the case of the Biden
pens and that this was done in the case
of the Biden Pen Center the Department
of Justice was immediately as was done
the Department of Justice was
immediately so I uh the the reading of
this statement is not going particularly
well for Joe Biden
um Jason kander had a very good tweet
about the contrast between the Biden and
the Trump classified document situation
now those of you who really know me know
that I could not care less about whether
there's a d or an R next to Joe Biden or
Trump's name when it comes to how these
situations should be handled investigate
all of them and I think what will become
very clear as a piece of my microphone
just exploded uh is that the
circumstances are of course so
dramatically different and Jason
kander's tweet was quote
classified documents a shopping analogy
as Biden walked out the buzzer went off
and he realized he mistakenly failed to
pay for an item in his cart he went back
in and returned it Trump stuffed items
in his pockets when the buzzer sounded
he ran to his car and peeled out I have
said it all week and I will say it again
investigate everyone this doesn't
exonerate Donald Trump any more than an
accused murderer would be exonerated
because of someone else accused of
murder somewhere else in a completely
unrelated case these are two completely
separate things
the facts are different the reaction was
different the circumstances are
different and it's so evident that
everything about these two situations is
so so different so Fox is getting a lot
of mileage from this Donald Trump I'm
sure is thrilled about the fact that
this is going on
but these are two very different
situations they should both be
investigated and let's let the cards
fall where they may see how I'm not
saying oh but let the cards fall where
they may and Peter Ducey is gonna get
his licks there's no doubt about it
um but uh it does not do a damn thing to
exonerate Donald Trump
you know I have a very acute Newfound
appreciation for how busy being a new
parent makes you if you have a little
one at home like me here's something
really easy you can do to simplify your
life our sponsor little spoon is your
One-Stop shop for healthy easy meal time
and snack time for your baby toddler or
big kid delivered right to your door
little spoon delivers fresh organic baby
food which comes in single ingredient
varieties or multi-textured purees
little spoon is meals for toddlers and
big kids they're free of junk and taste
great even the pickiest eaters love them
I've even tried many of them myself they
really are grape having healthy snack
time is so easy with little spoons
organic smoothies which come in
convenient pouches in great flavors like
strawberry banana shake purple carrot
acai I love purple carrots I'm gonna
admit that my girlfriend and I have had
a great experience with our little spoon
subscription it just makes life easier
anything to reduce the chaos is a great
thing little spoon is giving my audience
50 off your first order go to
littlespoon.com and use code Pacman 50
off all one word the info is down below